the u.n resolution was passed 22 to 11
with 14 countries abstaining
it calls on the sri lankan government to
ensure investigation and prosecution of
crimes
relating to human rights violations and
international human rights law
it also reflects the high commission's
findings that the human rights situation
has deteriorated with particular
concerns for human rights defenders in
civil society space
and members of different ethnic and
religious communities
including tamils muslims and christians
sri lanka lobbied hard against a
resolution and its friends stood by the
country
all countries should abide by the
purposes and principles of the human
charter
respect the sovereignty and independence
of other countries and abandoned the
practice of interfering in other
countries internal affairs
human rights activist bhavani fonseca
watched closely as the crucial session
progressed
basic notion of respecting rights
respecting dignity has to start
and leadership from the political actors
from the government from the opposition
in terms of trying to achieve
a peaceful solution is essential so the
resolution is merely
just an indicator that so much is
required
but really it's up to the sri lankans
now to take this step forward
but people like salvarani are struggling
to do that
in december 2000 her husband vil varasa
and their six and thirteen-year-old sons
were killed by soldiers of the sri
lankan army part of a group of eight
civilians
hacked to death and buried here in
mirosovil in the northern peninsula
army staff sergeant sunil ratnayaka was
convicted on eight counts of murder
while four other soldiers were acquitted
in 2015.
the supreme court upheld the conviction
but president got away rajpaksa pardoned
ratnayaka a few months after taking
office
the man who was convicted of the murders
was sentenced to death
but this government came and freed him
they didn't tell us or ask us about what
we felt
there's no justice or law that is
respected
the pardon marked the first of a series
of reversals
under president rajapaksa which the un
says threatened to reverse the limited
but important gains made in recent years
tuesday's resolution said these include
increasing militarization
eroding judicial independence impunity
and political obstruction of
accountability
increased marginalization of tamils and
muslims
shrinking democratic space and
restriction of media freedoms
the sri lankan government says the
resolution overreaches the mandate of
the u.n rights body
this resolution will polarize sri lankan
society and adversely affect
economic development peace and harmony
u.n human rights chief michel bachelet
had wanted sanctions against senior
figures of sri lanka's government
this resolution falls short of that
mandating the collecting
and preserving of evidence of war crimes
the rajapaksa administration
says that's unwarranted unjustified
unhelpful and divisive but for families
of victims
it may help shed light on what happened
to their loved ones
mila fernandez al-jazeera colombo